- Hi, I'm Mark Ruffalo, and
this is how I became Rob Bilott.
(upbeat music)
Becoming Rob Bilott was appealing to me
because he was an atypical hero.
He's the guy who is part of
a corporate defense company
that decides to take
on a case for a farmer
that he knew while he was
growing up against DuPont,
the biggest chemical company in the world.
And he ends up uncovering
the biggest contamination
and poisoning of the world
from this one little case.
DuPont is knowingly poisoning
70,000 local residents
for the last 40 years.
My first impression of Rob Bilott
was somebody that was
very modest, soft-spoken,
thoughtful, and very gentle,
something very sweet in him,
even though he was taking
on this corporate giant,
which made it a really
interesting kind of character,
and not what you would
think of as somebody
who tackles something as
enormous as he does in this film.
I spent days with Rob Bilott.
One of our first meetings,
I was meeting him
at the Taft Building in Cincinnati.
We were meeting at a particular time,
and I showed up a little bit early,
and I got to observe
him for maybe 10 minutes
without him knowing that I was there.
I watched him, I actually followed him.
He was walking around,
and I was just regarding the way
he walked and the way he moved.
He was on set with me all the time.
I would call him all hours of the night
to ask him things about
like what kind of snacks
did you eat during this, what
did you put in your coffee,
to why, why would you continue
on something so difficult
and lonely and alienating for so long?
But there was a lot of
questions that I had
about motivation because
this guy, what he did,
was so antithetical to
what most of us think
it is to be successful in America.
Here he was in this
giant important law firm
that defended the biggest
companies in the world,
and he was working on
behalf of a cow farmer
in West Virginia who had
a 12th grade education.
And he completely left the
American ideal of success
to go down this other
more just and, I'd say,
although he's not openly
spiritual or talks about spirit,
was a spiritual path for righteousness.
I wanted to know why.
What compels somebody to do that?
I don't know that I ever
really got to the bottom
of that question, other
than there's just something.
He had a greater belief in justice
than he did in things, in material.
These companies, they have
all the money, all the time,
and they'll use it, trust me.
I know, I was one of them.
- [Farmer] You're still one of 'em.
- There's a scene that was
particularly hard for me
and challenging was a scene
when Rob has the breakdown.
His physical body just sort of breaks down
underneath the pressure.
I don't understand that.
I've never experienced anything like that,
so to make that work and
to have it be believable
was something that I was
struggling with a lot,
and I had a hard time shooting.
I probably shot that probably six times.
Then there's a couple scenes,
there's probably a six-page monologue
where he basically lays
out the entire history
of Teflon and C8 and
that was challenging too.
To be able to tell that
story and to do it in a way
that has the same kind of
thoughtfulness that Rob has,
and not as an actor try to go
for like the big emotional speech,
but be as honest as possible
to who Rob Bilott was,
that's challenging and that
takes a lot of discipline,
and it takes some bit of courage as well.
So, it was hard for me.
- You want to take
everything that you know,
and turn it against an
iconic American company
like an informant, isn't that right?
- Yes.
I'm inspired by David and Goliath stories
because we all sort of relate to them,
we all understand those dynamics so well,
and we oddly identify with the David.
We understand that we're
living under an oppressive
kind of system at times,
and we always want the
little guy to be able to beat
this monster, this giant.
I just think it's great storytelling
and it's a storytelling
that we really understand
somewhere deep inside of
us in a really simple way.
The system is rigged.
They want us to think it'll protect us.
We protect us, we do.
(dramatic music)
(ignition switch dinging)